vous avez aussi une frustration réelles
des gens sur place c'est à dire que je
me rappelle une sexagénaire cannoise qui
étaient là qui commence à donner des
coups de sac à main ou journalistes en
disant mais mais mais vous vous le voyez
tous les jours laissez-moi voir monsieur
zemmour laissez-moi
vous venez de cannes vous avez suivi
éric zemmour tout le week-end est-ce que
ça va est-ce que c'était intense ça va
ça va c'était un déplacement sur deux
jours moi je suis arrivé par par avion
le vendredi soir où on fait on est allé
à antibes
parce que eric zemmour devait rencontrer
des avocats du barreau de nice d'antibes
de cannes du coin j'ai vu les équipes on
sentait qu'elle avait le sourire qu'elle
avait un peu la pêche qui sortait d'une
semaine horribilis avec plusieurs
polémiques
une sorte de plafond dans les sondages
finalement elle avait trouvé l'antidote
à cette mauvaise séquence qui est en
fait les ralliements et puis surtout
on arrive le vendredi soir et le
vendredi soir un peu tard après le dîner
commence à s'ébruiter et puis ça
s'officialise très vite la venue de
gilbert collard qui rallie à son tour
eric zemmour mais c'est pas du tout pour
ça que je suis allé sur ce déplacement
c'est même pas pour la réunion publique
dont on va parler qui était
impressionnante à cannes que j'y suis
allé moi j'y suis allé pour une séquence
qui est la séquence du marché pourquoi
est ce que pour la journaliste politique
c'est très précieux de voir un candidat
déambuler au milieu des gens en meeting
c'est des affidés en gros c'est des
sympathisants c'est des gens qui sont
déjà convaincus mais là vraiment un
marché c'est à dire que les gens ne
savaient pas qu'ils allaient venir non
plus c'est important de voir ce contact
c1 c'est un révélateur très important
est éloquent de personnalités sur le
marché ou sur scène comment avez-vous
trouvé les émirs samedi
c'était un vrai chirac quoi il était
assez drôle parce que s'est révélé très
à l'aise et que je console le petit
enfant qui pleure parce que impressionné
par tous ces journalistes par ce monde
et que je fais la bise à la vieille dame
et que je rigole avec le patron de
bistrot et que je vais sentir les fruits
enfin je veux dire c'est un chat quand
campagne qu'on va pas un balladur
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui a un rôle particulier et
très politique dans cette scène c'est
sarah knafo qui est la plus proche
conseillère d'eric zemmour qui voyant
que la scène marche en fait que
plusieurs médias sont là pour filmer
pour pour crédibiliser ce moment pour
renforcer en fait la spontanéité elle va
devant les caméras prendre le
poissonnier par la manche en disant
allez on le fait elle prend le numéro
devant nous elle dit ok bah je vous
envoie un texto on va on va on va
vraiment faire ça à quoi c'est de la
communication mais c'est intéressant
en fait ce qui se passe il ya un
candidat et puis il ya bien il ya une
foule autour de lui et au plus proche de
lui il ya ce qu'on appelle la neutre la
meute c'est assez impressionnant c'est
une cinquantaine 60 journalistes vous
avez les cameramans qui prennent
beaucoup de place et prennent beaucoup
de place mais ils sont pas très mobile
donc il faut se faufiler entre eux et
puis vous avez les photographes c'est
les plus violents eux et ils jouent des
coudes et des épaules pour avoir la
meilleure prise la meilleure photo à
l'instant t donc faut éviter les coups
de coude passé entre les jambes bon et
puis vous avez aussi une frustration
réelles des gens sur place c'est à dire
que je me rappelle une sexagénaire
cannoise qui étaient là qui commence à
donner des coups de sac à main aux
journalistes en disant mais mais mais
vous vous le voyez tous les jours
laissez-moi voir monsieur zemmour
laissez-moi voir bah voilà donc faut
gérer un peu ce stress en sachant que
tout le monde bouge sur le candidat
marche donc la meute bout j'avais pas
aller pas statique donc c'est une
épreuve un peu physique
en sortant du marché je me suis dit est
une vraie ferveur allait pas feinte il
ya eu des larmes 1 il ya eu des gens à
la limite du malaise
c'était un concert de hard rock presque
lançait donc il a vraiment retourner ce
marché le meeting c'est pareil c'est
4500 personnes il ya dix ans ça aurait
été lambda pas deux mois du premier tour
alors qu'on sort du coc vide que a pas
de tension politique vraiment très forte
à deux mois de la présidentielle c'est
énorme d'avoir 4500 personnes dans cette
salle qui était en plus dans une zone
industrielle de cannes n'était pas au
centre de câlins sur remobilise ceux qui
sont pour lui il ya vraiment un acte
militant très très fort ce qui fait que
c'est un signe d'appartenance il faut y
aller il faudrait être vue sur les
réseaux sociaux de très loin c'est celui
qui fait les plus grosses audiences
celui qui fait les plus gros engagements
sur les réseaux sociaux et ça se voit
aussi dans ses salles c'est là où il ya
le plus de monde à part emmanuel macron
aucun autre candidat mais capable de le
faire quand est ce que votre prochain
rendez vous le prochain où je vais et là
il va se déplacer donc ce vendredi sur
les terres de guillaume pelletier donc
se rallier devenu de l'est républicain
donc en loir et cher eric zemmour à un
rythme très soutenu et ce depuis depuis
sa précampagne de septembre mais c'est
assez logique parce qu'en fait ils
arrivent de nulle part c'est un
challenger c'est un peu le maverick de
l'élection il est obligé d'en faire
beaucoup plus que les autres pour gagner
à une vitesse
record la notoriété et la crédibilité
il fait deux à trois déplacements là où
c'est la plupart de ses concurrents soit
n'en font pas encore soit en font un
c'est assez intense